the Holland America cruise line company
called the plight of its passengers a
humanitarian situation but after days of
uncertainty the zaandam on its sister
ship the Rotterdam have finally docked
in Florida his and arms journey began in
Argentina in early March
but after passengers began to get sick
Chile and several other nations refused
to let them disembark almost 200 people
now have flu-like symptoms for elderly
passengers died on board at least two
testing positive for kovat 19 will good
afternoon
initially officials in Florida cited
health concerns the state's governor
saying foreign nationals were not
welcome following coordination with
several agencies it was finally agreed
to let the ships into US waters there
are also many other people on board who
need our help who may be not be
Americans but are human beings and they
also need help returning to their
countries this is what makes the United
States such a great country
let's uphold the principles that make us
a great nation and be compassionate and
humane to other evil healthy passengers
were transferred to the Rotterdam those
with symptoms of the corona virus will
be treated at local hospitals others are
flying back to their respective
countries on chartered flights in all
there were around two and a half
thousand passengers and crew earlier
this week US President Donald Trump
spoke about the stranded travelers a lot
of Canadians a lot of British on the
ship and they're coming to take the
people that are on the ship back to
their homeland
Canada's coming a UK is coming and we
have a lot of and we have Americans we
have some people that are quite sick for
these people this is the end of a
nightmarish journey that was supposed to
last two weeks
it's thought some passengers will remain
on board while they're treated others
are not so lucky
cruise ships have now become a symbol of
fear ever since the corona virus
pandemic was announced the Grand
Princess was stranded off the coast of
California for days while officials
squabbled over its fate while as on DOM
and the Rotterdam have now been allowed
to disembark here in Florida it's
estimated nine thousand passengers on
ten cruise ships remain at sea and a
gala Carol disease
Miami Florida